قضيه ترامب تحولت الى معركه سياسيه
والصفات بين اعضاء الحزبين فحتى غريم
ترامب الجمهوري حاكم ولايه فلوريدا رانديس
خرج عن صمته منتقدا المدعي العام في منهات
ورغبه ان ديسنتوس المرشح الجمهوريه
المحتمل للرئاسه تعهد بان مكتبه لن يتدخل
في تسليم ترامب الى نيويورك الا انه لم
يقدم الدعم للتراب وبدلا من ذلك بدا انه
يسخر من الموقف الذي وضع ترامب نفسه فيه
خاصه انه يحاول العوده للحياه السياسيه من
خلال الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه حاكم
فلوريدا قال في مؤتمر صحفي اقيم في
الولايه انه لا يعرف ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث
في قضيه دفع الاموال لشراء صمت ممثله
واضاف انه يفضل عدم الحديث عن ذلك مشيرا
الى انه لديه قضايا وصفها بالحقيقيه
للتعامل معها في فلوريدا بدلا من ذلك
[موسيقى]